(bell dings)
- Okay, a stranger mistakes,
oh this has happened.
A stranger mistakes
you for another person.
Do you, A, Roll with it,
pretending you are the
other person, (laughing)
or B, Embarrass the
stranger by correcting them?
What would you do, Cheryl?
- Ooh!
- Uh, I have rolled with it.
- I have as well.
Yeah.
So I was on a plane, and
this person came up and said,
"Oh my gosh, I love you."
And I said, "That's so nice, thank you."
And they said, " I love Modern Family."
And I said, " I do too!"
- (laughing) Oh my God!
And they said, "Can I get my
picture with you, Julie Bowen?"
And I was like, "Uh, yes."
(laughing)
- I did the same.
- Did you?!
- It was, and we don't,
y'all look similar,
I do not look like this person.
This girl came up to me
and was like, "Oh my God."
"Your song "So Small"
is one of my favorites."
And I kept thinking, "I
don't have a song "So Small."
And then she said another
song, and I was like,
"Oh, you think I'm Carrie Underwood."
And I was like, and I
literally look nothing
like Carrie Underwood.
And I was like, and then I
was so embarrassed for her
that I just, she was
like, "Can you sign this?"
(laughing) And I totally
signed Carrie Underwood.
(laughing)
I think that might be illegal.
- Just so you can get out of it.
I mean this one lady on
the airplane one time
thought I was Kim Coles,
and I didn't know how
to tell her otherwise,
'cause she was kind of old.
So I'm like, "Maybe
this is her dying wish."
And so she just kept
asking me about TV stuff,
I was like, "Yep."
And at the end of the flight
I just gave her an autograph,
and I was like, "Have
fun, Ester." or Ethel,
whatever her name was.
But sometimes you gotta go with it,
but I like putting people in their place,
'cause I am not Raven-Symone!
- Oh.
- What?!
Do people say that?
- That's not so Raven!
(laughing) Oh my God, that's awesome!